hey real quick yeah I guess
excuse me did I did I ask something
difficult of yourself cuz that's a lot
of attitude right no no I said I'd do it
okay I just don't know why you can't get
off your fat ass and do it yourself
because it's a Sunday because I'm a
Sunday go to hell yeah oh is it Sunday
then I shouldn't pray dear God please
help my boyfriend look less like Buddha
and more like Keanu Reeves lookie here
Saints no child call me fat again and
see what happens yeah let me now we've
been together for a while now you know
but you know we fight it's what we do
you just you don't love someone unless
you hate their first right
[Music]
honestly I hate him but I love him too
much to leave him and I put too much
time into him to leave now that's that's
some funny stuff right there yeah okay
let's not talk about what I do wrong
let's talk about what you do wrong yeah
you had this weird tendency to overreact
you know that no yeah I don't know where
we can come back to save money is that
are you serious right now okay let me
show you something real quick okay see
all this right here $300 of facials and
manicures are you kidding me right now
that's a necessity haha that's funny
how's that my face that you look at I'm
getting sick and tired of her always
screaming rape I've never said I have
said it before but it was a joke haha
how is rape a joke alright look it's not
like you've been perfect either he said
some messed-up [ __ ] to me put your hands
on me again see if I don't give you an
uppercut you know what that is bet you
do
man how would you and your lumpy ass
titties ya know you spent both your
angles at the same time hey baby your
nipples look like when these pepperonis
doing yeah well I hope your babies come
out looking confused and ugly just like
yes
wait if we're together wouldn't they be
your babies too yeah we'll see about
that
exactly no exactly let's talk let's talk
about what you've done to them huh
yeah let's do it hmm I'm gonna cut your
dick in half so you can piss into
toilets one of your balls looks like and
the other one looks like a hamster I
thought I bought you on the street today
but it was just a homeless woman your
boots remind me of my grandma your dick
is small yeah you see what the problem
is she doesn't listen when I speak you
never let me speak so you're doing it
right now see you
that I don't know you insinuate things
before I actually do no no the problem
is that I always know when you're about
to do something wrong I can hear it
coming like a [ __ ] train and I have
yet to be incorrect time is clear the
record you are not Tiger Woods in me in
the hallway you all know for a second
excuse me
Louise she what's your name
shut up give me that hello yeah look
you're gonna have to find your own fat
loser because this one is taken and let
me tell you something else bet oh oh my
god him I I didn't know no I'm you know
what just give me one second your mom
would like to talk to you again she's
black
shake shake very much we have not even
started to come here okay you don't need
to cover internal I've said everything I
need to say like living without weird
but with like a twitch why did you
remember to get the paper towels in the
tissues no your god can you pick him up
for me of course love you
love you too what please fix my
boyfriend's legs so we can get on Wii
Fit and get a body like Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]